但凡有经验的人都不会建议说你必须分居两年再去打官司，
如果谁那么建议你的话，
那他纯属是门外汉，
我们两个是自由恋爱，
挺早就都结婚了，
也已经有了孩子，
现在7岁多，
这些年他的控制欲非常非常的强，
期间我也有过这个离婚的这个想法以及行动，
但是都没有实现，
现在的状态就是前几天吧，
演变的非常的恶劣，
这个态度直接他跟我动手，
我也有还手啊，
我们两个都有受伤，
第二天的时候我就直接就工作就辞了，
我就走了，
我现在想的是我们情绪都太不稳定了，
为啥工作就给辞了呢？
因为他那个人特别的极端，
他知道我的工作地点，
他会去我的上班的地方去闹，
不让我去安心的工作，
那我问一下，
就咱们有什么把柄在他手上，
怕他闹吗？
我没有什么把柄，
他闹了之后就是你一定会被开除吗？
也不是说一定会被开除，
我工作的地点是超市，
有一部分是这个原因，
但是一在很久前我就已经计划这次就是要跟他离这个婚，
但是跟他有说正常走协议离婚是肯定是不会同意的，
我也咨询过，
就是一些个法律上这个相关的问题，
就是说必须得提前分居或者怎么样，
如果说起诉的话，
我在这个这半年期间一直在计划这个事情，
倒也不是啊，
不是说要离的话必须要提。
才分区才能经历啊，
我之前有看到你的直播切片，
然后那个NPD型人格嘛，
他非常的符合这类的，
这个人格就是他平时所有习惯，
然后就是经常说卖就卖，
各种的贬低我，
但实际上家里所有的需要出面的问题都是我来做的，
包括这个什么人情浪费儿啊，
或者是干嘛的都是我来出头的，
然后他什么都不行，
他找的一个工作呢，
还是他的亲戚朋友给他介绍的，
现在就相对比较体面一点的工作，
在那个公司里，
他现在就觉得我的工作配不上他，
但是我的工资比他的工资还要高，
他的工作只是现在比较体面，
有五险一金这种，
然后他就非常看不起我，
平时经常的贬低我，
我就非常受不了，
而且他控制的非常严格，
就是我挣得钱，
我自己花都是不行的，
就是必须要经过他的同意，
我就想着说，
那我就干脆就离婚就得了，
现在就是我也不知道这事走的对不对，
我现在就是已经离开那个城市了，
然后呢，
孩子现在就是一直都是他爷爷奶奶在看，
我们两个一直在外地打工，
如果他是动手，
嗯较难，
如果他真的有NPD的这种倾向啊，
反正咱超市那个工作吧，
又不是什么铁饭碗，
又不是特别特别特别好的工作，
辞了也就辞了，
离开也没问题啊，
没问题那就行了，
关键是昨天晚上我婆婆还给我打电话，
说我自私的说我不管孩子，
老后说孩子怎么怎么着的，
就是那个。
也挺崩溃的，
他现在就是比如说他家里现在在给他找心理医生，
说他看看病怎么怎么着的，
但是我的想法肯定是这个事儿就不能过来，
但是我一定要等到就是两年以后才去提吗？
还是说我现在如果提也有可能，
其实我更建议啊，
如果你铁了心了，
打定了主意，
不想跟他过了，
那就尽早提，
为什么呢？
因为你第一把他不同意的话，
你可能还得等半年再提一次，
前前后后这么算下来的话，
怎么也得一年多，
如果你等两年之后再去提的话，
程序是一样的，
就是第一次还是他不同意，
那90%以上还是一不了，
程序一样，
就是有分居证明也不行了，
是吧，
你证明不了啊，
那那应该是一个程序还不行啊。
第一你证明不了，
我俩是因为感情不和分开的，
他打我的这种天生的这种山爱什么的都有，
留作证据也不行，
很难。
我跟你说啊，
那把你这个事儿到哪种程度上才有可能被采信呢？
就报钩记录了，
有住院记录了，
伤情鉴定了，
这种情况下才有可能被采信，
像光是你自己一张照片的话，
他马上就说那是他自己摔的，
你很难证明这个东西明白吗？
所以说我们作为但凡有经验的人，
都不会建议说你必须分居两年再去打官司，
如果谁那么建议你的话，
那他纯属是门外汉，
他根本就不是一个离婚律师，
到现在直接提就可以了，
直接提就行，
那就是我们提的理由就是。
其实就是感情不和呗，
那需要把动手这些事儿提上去吗？
可以提上去啊，
就是你举证到哪个程度，
法官信任采信到哪个程度，
这是两码事儿，
你可以提，
然后那这种情况我再问一下，
就是我的孩子这一块儿呢，
因为昨天我婆婆这儿就是很生气，
就是意思说你孩子是给我生的吗？
那么我给你们带着，
你们说吵架也就不管了，
什么也不管了，
怎么怎么着的，
孩子这一块我需要去争取吗？
法院判的话可能会判给谁呀？
如果你俩都争取孩子的话，
可能会判给他，
为什么呢？
因为孩子一直是爷爷奶奶在带有这种可能性啊，
因为我就干脆没有必要去争取呢，
还是要争取，
因为我争取这个是留下痕迹，
将来对孩子有交代明白了，
你明白啊，
明白就行了，
行了，
没有问题了，
好，
拜拜啊，
记得点赞关注哦。